[Music]
if you worked a little
harder then you'd have a lot
more so the blame and the shames on you
for being so damn poor it ain't the
price gouging and it ain't the
inflation it ain't everyone above you
trying to make a buck from you in school
in the whole congregation I had that
reduced lunch I had the benefit
cards never occurred to me to blame my
family for life being so damn hard I
should have paid
attention back when I was in
school and I could figure up the text I
I know a lot of facts I missed the class
where they taught the rules I was
memorizing capitals I was in the spell
and
be I must have skipped the part where
they taught the heart of private Equity
I was selling chocolate bars I had a
disorder I was cutting up a frog got
lost in the fog learning and a play
recorder if you only worked a little
[Music]
harder if you a little
harder if you work a little
harder ah
if you worked a little
harder and you'd have a lot
more so the shame and the blame's on you
for being so damn poor it ain't the
banks and it ain't the
taxes it ain't the payday loans and high
rent homes and predatory fees and
practices wave your dumb
flag whatever it
means you should ask yourself when it
comes to health of the poor really let
free if you work a little
[Music]
harder if you work a little
harder you'd have a l
more so the blame and the shames on you
for being so damn poor yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
go ahead Jo
[Music]
[Applause]
p
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]